[Music]  to remind me of my screw-up you know I  don't think we're ever gonna understand  each other they're gonna come here every  Saturday just to graduate with all these  other weirdos and criminals I keep a  close watch on this heart of mine I  can't so this is where you come every  Saturday instead of practice tragic I  keep the eggs out for the times I'd buy  some restricted area a guy's skirt you  should have pointed that out wait I did  now something happened over there okay  i'm not the same i'm strong how strong  and insanely strong  you  like we need to go back I'm gonna talk  across with her and then you jump PCK  let's go no no no Kanta Jason that's not  okay  I've killed Rangers before it's  happening  [Music]  that spot row do you know Spirent